[Music] It's
quite difficult to approach using the speed at which the legs are stretched back and attack at the same time.However, at
that point, I choose a technique that proves it's not a bug technique.I
don't understand constipation yet, but I have the power.  It's a
great opportunity to attack, but the
correct
answer is that it's difficult to follow up. Haru, la, la, la, it's
fast. You can't escape
anyway. Then, as always,
just return with a straight line charge or E-fist.
What's that?
[Music]
Chapter chapter is activated twice.  If you don't know what this is, I
think you can return it, but let's try it.The first time I did it, I was able to get through the round.The current chapter was duplicated.Ah, this is the first time I've seen this pattern.What do you think?Both of you were hit and
judged.  In principle, it's a pile bunker, but
with that, you can't duplicate gauge moves.It's a
doppelganger-related bug after all, right?There
was someone who verified that it shouldn't have been possible to create clones at the same coordinates.Also, you can't
use a chimera on a doppelganger.  If
not, then it
will be confirmed if the tax can be reproduced.Congratulations, Dragonfly.Although it is tentative,
you are the first to discover this bug.Congratulations.Bo,
congratulations.